hallo berlin ich stehe hier zusammen mit
wladimir klitschko wladimir wir haben
gerade gehört dass bereits 14 kinder in
diesem krieg gestorben sind du bist
selbst vater einer tochter was macht das
mit dir gerade solche nachrichten sollte
das herz hier die krise und nicht
blutet es
gibt keine fremde kinder
die kinder die fremd sind es ist
grauenhaft diese bilder zu sehen
grauenhaft das macht das krieg dass
russland angefangen hat auch kinder
sterben es gibt leider
nichts was nicht zu stören sein kann
nicht nur infrastruktur sondern das
menschliche leben wird zerstört wir
haben die grausamen bilder archiv
gesehen aus alpinen im vorort von kiew
dort wurden zivilisten getötet die
teilweise noch eine tasche dabei hatten
die raus wollten wenn man dass sie diese
raketen die dort einschlagen wie schlimm
kann es noch kommen
es scheint zu sein was sind halt windows
wurden lassen die cluster bombs die
verbotene
die dann auf die
wohngebieten im heike
gefallen sind und dabei natürlich die
zivilisten gestorben sind
das ist grauenhaft dass fast 1000
raketen waren abgeschossen richtung
ukraine und dabei witze stört nicht nur
infrastruktur matschies leben sondern
auch die nuklear plans werden betroffen
also atomkraftwerken und wir haben genug
davon fallen wir haben auch reaktoren
die viel mehr als nur kraftwerken sind
und wir reden und wer eine humanitäre
katastrophe bei wir reden gerade über
eine wild katastrophe weil das was in
der ukraine erscheinen und passieren
kann kann fukushima und tschernobyl in
mehrfachen dimensionen seien und davon
werden wir alle betroffen diese krieg
muss gestoppt werden so schnell wie
möglich und es kann passieren
wenn auch die verbunden der ukraine die
frauen die ukraine mit sanktionen jede
art und weise gegen russland nicht gegen
die menschen und zivilbevölkerung von
russland aber die die regierung
die schickt ihre truppen in die ukraine
und menschen zu töten und zu versteuern
das hat kann sehen dass es sein ein
krankes kriegt er kein verständnis
finden kann jetzt hat der deutsche
bundeskanzler olaf scholz dass
deutschland weiterhin öl und gas aus
russland beziehen will was
sagst du dazu
werden wir es nicht stoppen
zu finanzieren diesen krieg damit die
gelder die aus deutschland fließen
werden werden auf militär- und weiter
ausgegeben das muss man verstehen man
auf eine seite bekommen gas und ich
verstehe dass die wirtschaft
funktionieren muss ab oder andere seite
werden die geschosse voll geladen und
dabei wird viel zerstört viel mehr als
man die wirtschaft
wir sind teil europa wir sind im herzen
europas geopolitisch gesehen
ukraine muss frieden haben
sanktionen sind ganz wichtig um diese
vision russische aggression diesem krieg
was fußball angefangen hat zu stoppen
das muss mir gemeinsam tun wir machen
schon alles hier auf dem boden in der
ukraine alles möglich aber wir brauchen
unterstützung wir brauchen humanitäre
hilfe wir brauchen finanzielle hilfe wir
brauchen militärcoup nennt das hilfe wir
klären das alles schon selbst her wie
erklärst du dir das deine zweite heimat
sag ich mal deutschland da so viel
zögerlicher ist als die usa zum beispiel
die ja gesagt haben dieses embargo muss
seine öl und gas woran liegt das um
ehrlich zu sein
es gibt
ängste und es gibt das schlimmste sünde
feige zu sein
feige zu sein heißt weglaufen das ist
toll ich heraus von dem herausforderung
ich möchte nicht deutschland als zweige
zu sehen nein das möchte ich nicht nein
ich möchte nicht deutschland oder das
westliche welt unsere verbündeten als
frei gesehen ängste sind
da ich verstehe die sorgen ich verstehe
das aber es ist ganz wichtig nicht in
diese schlimmste sünde was man haben
kann weil es
ist nicht nur mit ukraine sich gestoppt
sein wird es kann sein dass die
russische truppen weiter gehen und die
werden das tun und da gibt es leider
kein vertrauen mit diesem grünen
korridor wo die zivilisten
für lassen sollten die die gebete man
sieht dass die von panzer an
zivilfahrzeuge abschießen und die
menschen
zivilisten starben diesen fahrzeugen
lasst uns kurz über krieg sprechen wo
wir sind in der hauptstadt momentan die
welt schaut auf kiew und viele fragen
sich wir sind jetzt am tag 13 glaube ich
dieses krieges
wovon geht ihr aus wann wird sozusagen
diese grausame möglicherweise grausam
schlacht hier um die innenstadt um kiew
beginnen und wie bereitet man sich vor
und das grausame spotten das ist
grauenhaft
tief ist die hauptstadt der ukraine und
das ist das ziel die auf stadt zu
treffen
ich bin vergangenen tagen genauso wie
heute ist der internationale frauentag
und ich brauchte widmen auch die
ukrainische frauen
unglaublich viel ukrainische frauen
die in der mehr angezogen sind
individuelle verteidigen kann gezogen
sind die stehen mit den männern um ihre
land ihre kinder zu verteidigen das ist
eine enorme stärke und enorme motivation
die wahrheit ist auf unsere seite wir
haben keinen gegriffen und angegriffen
wurden ich bin stolz auf die ukrainische
frauen ich bin stolz auf die ukraine ich
bin stolz ein ukraine zu sein diese
wille ist enorm enorm stark wir stehen
zusammen wie sie nicht allein wir machen
alles was uns abhängt wir brauchen die
unterstützung die unterstützung wir
haben ein paar öl- und gas-embargo
gesprochen muss das sofort kommt muss
dieses öl und gasbranche aus deutschland
es muss sofort com es muss sofort
gestoppt werden jede depression mit
russland es muss es kann nicht sein dass
in einem monat oder wochen dass man die
entscheidung trifft was die bürokratie
betrifft es muss jetzt passieren nicht
die stunden entscheiden die minuten
entscheiden die minuten entscheiden
während wir hier reden die russische
truppen ziehen immer näher und dabei
werden auch menschen sterben
du bist seit wochen in der ukraine
zusammen mit vitali
letzte frage wie geht es euch
ich hoffe dass es nicht die letzte frage
nein wir werden natürlich weiß ich hoffe
dass es nicht die letzte frage warum
dazu erst die sumo ich
das weiß keiner wie wie weit es gehen
kann was auf uns zukommt ich strebe ich
hoffe
wir machen alles um frieden im ukraine
herzustellen alles mögliche und die
freiheit für die wir uns entschieden
haben muss auch bestehen genauso wie du
frieden also denkt weiterhin nicht
darüber nach das land zu verlassen
auf keinen fall das das gegenteil davon
dass die dass die ukraine die maus land
waren ziehen sich in die ukraine zurück
die aus dem ausland kommen zurück weil
das ist ein land das ist kein zuhause es
ihnen dankbar die mitglieds herzlichen
dank und damit zurück nach berlin